merci Sophie à tout à l'heure l'exode
historique des Allemands de l'Est les
premiers sont arrivés en Bavière pour
que vous compreniez bien cette
incroyable rué vers l'ouest sachez
qu'après avoir quitté leur pays ils se
sont réfugiés en Hongrie où ils ont
attendu plusieurs semaines que le
gouvernement hongrois les laisse partir
puis ils sont passés par l'Autriche pour
arriver enfin en RFA le feu vert a donc
été donné hier par les autorités de
Budapest cette mesure concerne dans
l'immédiat 6500 personnes Patricia
Coste
inconcevable libre
libre inconcevable ce sont les deux mots
qui reviendront le plus souvent dans les
témoignages des réfugiés est allemands
passés à l'ouest il n'arrivve tout
simplement pas encore à y croire à
défaut de mot pour s'exprimer un geste
que tous feront devant les caméras celui
de brandir le passeport vert de
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest leur nouveau
passeport distribué à la frontière
hongroise en échange de leur passeport
bleu d'Allemagne de
l'Est moyenne d'âge entre 20 et 30 ans
souvent très qualifiés ils se sont
précipités cette nuit dès l'annonce de
l'ouverture des frontières en grand
nombre de peur que les autorités ne
reviennent sur leur décision à pied à
moto en poussette
en panne
ou en train organisé en convoi Philippe
Rochot était à la
frontière la Croix Rouge allemande va
rester une semaine à la frontière elle
estime qu'elle devra accueillir 10000
personnes au moins dans un premier temps
mais elle est prête à faire face le
chancelier a demandé aux Allemands de
l'Ouest de bien accueillir les réfugi
mais les premières réactions des
Allemands à la frontière entre
l'Autriche et l'Allemagne fédéraleem
plutôt à de
l'indifférence dernier symbole a été
barré sur l'autocollant indiquant
l'appartenance au pays d'origine DDR
Allemagne de l'Est le D et le r ces
réfugiés ne sont plus
qu'Allemands évidemment vous vous en
doutez bien